like don't they investigate these fires
because because can't they just tell
what caused it like right away because
they have these people you know how they
investigate they go like this hey let me
show you some evidence back that's it
hey detective you find anything oh
nothing is saying okay exactly they'll
be like this oh you're just investigate
you know move stuff around
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right when you guys imagine a dairy
farm Catching Fire how many cows do you
think die in something like that well
can't they just use their milk to to I
would imagine yeah also but they're
idiots also this might sound dumb why
would a dairy farm catch on fire
isn't it just milk I know right what are
they doing was it because I didn't know
milk was French flammable that's like a
water tower that caught on fire I mean
this is gonna raise a lot of Suspicion
but how just ballpark how many calories
you think died normally a thousand I was
thinking zero because then they just
walk out of the farm it might sound
[__] up but it probably smelled
delicious
it probably smelled like [__] carne
asada
so in in 2020 that that was like the
last biggest dairy farm fire and 400
cows died 400 I overshot I said a
thousand but oh there's another one
another one happened Jesse the other day
this is common it's not common at all so
that's why this sounds a little
suspicious but so like when the cows are
being lined up to be milked or whatever
like they're all in one big closed
facility usually
um so a fire happened that's my say was
due to a piece of equipment
malfunctioning
and 18 000 cows die
whoa there's a beef shortage now no no
but they're dairy cows oh no so they
don't use them for yeah they don't use
them for me oh there's gonna be a milk
short yeah 18
000 cows [__] Alta they not gonna be
[__] literally burned to crisp wait
this sounds like a Chinese operation
they don't have any escape plan for the
cows to like let them go in case they
have any fire no sprinklers nothing nope
that's because you know what the Chinese
Playbook is what what they do this all
the time whether it's a supermarket or a
restaurant they they run a business then
they run it to the ground they're bored
so what they do is they set their own
[__] on fire claim insurance insurance
and then they get paid out then
family business or to sell the shell of
a restaurant back to another friend and
it just goes from like noodle planet to
now Noodle World to now noodle City to
now noodle Galaxy to Noodle it's but you
know it's the same [__] menu I've
seen this in The Sopranos yeah and they
just go like this the whole time and
every single time they just do a little
insurance payout you know interesting it
sounds like a good business model yeah
this is probably [__] like don't they
investigate these fires because because
can't they just tell what caused it like
right away because they have the
experience well yeah they investigate
but they also do you know how they
investigate they go like this hey let me
show you some evidence back that's it I
was dude looking
you find
you find anything oh nothing to say here
what's that exactly they'll be like this
oh you're just investigate you know move
stuff around
if you see something you like you can
keep it's five bucks
that's my gosh is Mr Lincoln have
something to say dude I actually
actually went wrong with me at a club
one time when you try to grease somebody
yeah but it was five bucks
and he said he looked at this and gave
it back to you I had like a cousin that
was like underage trying to get him in
the club I was like I know he's like 20
years old who cares and I just five
bucks
hey my man come on man and then he
literally went
[__] out of here put it in my face come
on come on man come on
make the [__] out of here come on don't
throw my money man that's good money to
get a taco I literally say yellow things
that you can buy with five bucks there's
a whole [__] meal at McDonald's right
now dude this is back in the early
thousands I don't know if insurance is
gonna cover it the way that it sounds I
mean they're so every one of those cows
they say the value is about 2 000 bucks
oh my God what the [__] dude what's the
math on a 36 000 like 3.6 million and
then you have to add in equipment and
structure loss and they said it could go
to the tens of millions dude so is this
insurance fraud I don't know I don't
know if it's Insurance are people saying
that it's fishy because of how it's been
it could be it could be a market dude
cows alone is 36 million we gotta get in
the cow business baby what because
there's 18 000 cows two G's a piece so
that's 36 million on just cows damn
that's a lot of milk dude that's um the
amount of cows that died they said it's
like 2 20 percent of the amount of cows
per day that are slaughtered the poor
cows is this kind of fishy because we
just had like a baby formula shortage
not so long ago that's that's the thing
that people are like and then now
they're hitting like because this is
like kid food you know and then now you
got milk getting [__] with let me tell
you something tell me if I
on the business let's say America's my
business
you need some control
you know there's certain things like hey
this is going too high it's going too
low makes sense like if you know this is
a business like this and there's people
that are like like there's too much milk
we need to get ready there's got to be
something they're like it just makes
sense to me oh my God something happened
oh we couldn't
have like oh that
that's like the people that own this
[__] you know the higher ups they're
kind of like we're getting too much into
shortage what do you want to do time to
burn some chaos looking you know have
you seen House of Cards yep first was
the chicken eggs right something
and there was a pork shortage during
covid remember that there's a pork
there's always a shortage of something
right right that's the new trend these
days everything is supply chain they
said it's weird too because there's
nothing in the law like
um so 18 000 charred cow carcasses
they're trying to figure out how to uh
dispose of that oh right because you
can't you can bury them you can't but
there's not there's nothing in the law
that that
um kind of
um specifies what to do when you have to
build a mass grave of like that many
cows because they're not supposed to be
just gave them to the [__] lions at
the zoos burned up cows
so you should see what we feed our dogs
they get all leftovers
they're like cremated basically they're
burnt they just spread their ashes over
the ocean dude but the thing is that
with that many of them it'll contaminate
wherever it goes so they can't even bury
it within 50 feet from any Wells or like
water source well well why can't we just
put it East Palestine man we'll set it
over there what if we just Palestine
what did we just keep it cooking
I'm trying to disappear yeah just keep
burning it hey my guy who stopped the
fire
[Music]
had the guy on the back [__] playing
Dust in the Wind as they're burning
man
you can't turn them into ashes and like
use them as something they said they're
still trying to figure out what to do
with them damn because they're trying to
it's not that they there's a million
things they could do but within the law
there's not yeah there's a lot of Bones
you know you can just make something but
if you keep it cooking
oh
[Music]
Start the Fire back up
so yeah it basically is our [__]
workers came up through with their
[__] cowboy hat oh sir the calves are
burning up and the whole thing we're
gonna turn off the fire leg
turn off
John
how about you keep it cooking
but but sir that the fire shot
keep it [__] cooking all right that's
what you wanted to
keep on cooking
keep it cooking it's by far the largest
uh dairy cow fire in his where was this
damn Texas oh [__] [__] that's a lot 18
000 cows you know people in Texas are
[__] sad as [__] and 400 is the
previous fatality game and they never
try to gallop away or something I don't
think they are inside the house they're
inside they're inside the milking
structure you know the huge it is really
big 18 000 18 000 is like a small City
like population small City wait who
started that fire they said it they said
it it's uh right now they think it's
from a piece of equipment malfunctioning
yeah just like [__] noodle whatever
the [__]
yeah yeah
you got NorCal on the five and there's
that area that has nothing but just dirt
and cows I'm going there tomorrow yeah
oh yeah I'm wondering tomorrow go to
Madera California
and I drive by that place and I'm always
like [__] reeks have you ever stopped
by the restaurant there Harris Ranch I
go right past it dude because there's a
there's a ranch there um one of my
favorite Shabu places actually gets
their meat from Harris Ranch oh cool so
when I drove by I was like oh there's a
restaurant has quickly here but it
smells oh [__] the whole time yeah even
in the restaurant a little bit
in the restaurant too are you guys not
Cowboys come on man because even at the
gas station when you're pumping gas just
that whole area from Miles smells like
[__] yeah they get used to it though the
locals yeah I don't smell a thing they
don't even shower I won't smell yeah
they're like oh kind of reeks huh what
are you dumbbell
I don't know like freedom to me I don't
know if this part is suspicious sounding
to you guys but
um there was only like one person that
was rescued from inside the structure
during that fire wait there were other
people there's only one guy like there's
no other people in danger
it just says that there were no human
casualties but one person was rescued
Chinese operation and uh taken to a
hospital but no I don't know because in
massive commercial farming situations a
lot of it's automated yeah I was gonna
say imagine being that guy that's a lot
of kids imagine just [__]
just like oh [__]
out of here dude [__] you should just
wait outside he said what happened I
didn't [__] turn it on and did some
[__] what happened I don't know if you
want to do they imagined that guy though
the handle breaks off like what is
though okay okay so what is like the
worst thing you ever did at like a job
or you're like holy [__] like let me try
to fix this before they come in I'll
tell you guys mine
you [__] God I used to work at
Coca-Cola and we used to get those
shipments dude the [__] cases the
little 12 packs and stuff and they will
bring like
so here's here's how they do it if you
guys don't [__] know they bring in
those big old [__] containers to
build like the displays you ever walked
in in like football like you see those
[__] guys made out of the cardboard
boxes and [__] but like the whole thing
looks like a [__] football they bring
those in like but sometimes it's like if
it doesn't sell I'll take them back or
whatever so
the store is kind of like borrowing them
oh [__] but I ended up like with the
forklift like I was just in my
headphones I was [__] you know
jamming out Jose
it was more like [__] rock and roll
you know like
that was not so wide you're working
those long hours you know you got to
stay awake yeah and I did a turn bro I I
didn't go all the way in with the lift I
only went like halfway so when I pulled
it out that thing just went
[__] the I'm hearing music so I didn't
get to hear the sound but I can imagine
the sound was crazy but it just went
I'm sure you can feel the sound and I'm
just like I just feel I just I thought
it was a couple of cases just
and then when I move the [__]
forklift I look a river oh of coke of
coke and it was getting worse because
the river Coke was coming I'm like oh
[__] so then I run back and I'm like
this is I could clean this up I can
clean this up I can make it happen right
and then before you know I come back
two
the river of coke went inside the fridge
fridge is slippery and a little fridge
thing why'd they build a fridge like
that but only not only that but it also
creeped it into the [__] piles and
piles of flour that they had for the
store and of course it was next to the
[__] flower dude it could have been
next to the chips or anything it was in
a [__] flower so that thing was
deteriorating and I'm just like oh it
was one of those things where you're
like what do I do I gotta call my boss
and I think I'm gonna have to pay for
all I would have just took my [__]
name
for some reason I don't know why
didn't you know what happened I did I
call the manager said uh um
um Steve and he's just like hold on
Buddy hold on I'm just gonna just put
the soda here and I'm like Steve you
gotta go back there man and he went back
there he's like holy [__] and he just
[__] runs around other guys the meth
head [__] warehouse guy comes in and
she's just like holy [__] you break the
challenge [__]
it's hard to get fired when you're like
in a one of those jobs it's one of those
like uh yeah like you get [__] so
much protection at those jobs you know
but they just send you fake classes of
how to use the forklift properly and
this and that because there's like 7 000
like Union laws that protect you oh yeah
big time but it was uh one of those that
the embarrassment I felt was rough
everybody just I don't even go to that I
couldn't I wasn't allowed to go in that
store no more they never had a video of
it yeah oh I'm pretty sure they did I
was just embarrassed I had to take out
the coke one by one dude it was a
[__] test dude
when you're when it's happening and
you're like you're panicking you're like
this is real life like this the chaos
that's happening right now is this real
life it's coming out like
especially liquid like that oh and you
can't just stop it and then the river's
just going into the fridge in the fridge
that was the worst part because
apparently like you have to scrape it
off and then it went on the side oh my
it did just have to like take out a
piece of the wall and it was disaster
you didn't have to do any of that work
no they pay for it but wow here's the
cause of it so you're just kind of like
this is everybody just [__] not
talking moving stuff and I'm just going
yeah all right guys like what did you
guys did this did my alarm went off dude
uh um on my break so
I'll be back do I take my breaks like no
because if I don't take my break I'm
gonna get in trouble so do I you know
what I mean and my boss came they all
took pictures they [__] did anyone
grab you I'll take a drug the [__]
Pepsi send you over to sabotage
oh dude I had to like take a [__]
piss test and all that drug oh my god
do you guys if you guys ever cut like
to us
foreign
[Music]